hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is a renowned historian and
journalist who most probably knows more
about the German capital Berlin than
many Germans he certainly knows more
about the wry stark building which is
now once again the home of the German
parliament he's published extensively on
the subject Michael Cullen is also a
translator and interpreter and he's
lived here I've worked this out I think
you've lived here longer than any other
guest we've had on the program
welcome to the chef Michael thank you in
fact if I've got my math right it's your
50th anniversary of living in Berlin
this year you've done it well yeah 50
years yeah and I must ask you initially
what was it like in 1964 if we bear in
mind that in 1964 Nelson Mandela was
sentenced to life imprisonment and then
went to jail for a six year it was also
the year the Beatles played the Ed
Sullivan Show mean this is a long time
so tell us what was it like a young
American arriving in Berlin well I was
here because I was giving some lectures
and I would this then teaching English
American English and the city was there
were a lot of rooms still around the
course and dad didn't have any
high-rises there was nothing like that
not even the Europa Center which is 20
storeys high was it was under
construction at the time so these things
were not there and they were there were
trams running through the streets in
West Berlin
there were many streets which still had
cobblestones and there were telephone
booths telephone boxes the British would
call them all over the place to make
telephone calls and you needed 20
pfennigs
to make a telephone call and it wasn't
very easy and nowadays 50 years later we
all have cell phones or portables so
life was very very different yeah
and what actually brought you here
because you were a student of Russian
language and literature mm-hmm but you
came to Germany to Hannover I believe
first to Munich uh-huh and I worked at
Radio Liberty there for seven months as
an intern oh because of my
russian-speaking abilities I had studied
Russian and college and then I got a
scholarship to the u.s. to a college
there to Columbia University to do a
masters came back to Germany after not
finishing my master's as a teacher of
English and Hannover in a middle school
and then when Kennedy was assassinated
that was in November of 63
I wanted to see Berlin which had reacted
so emotionally to the assassination and
a friend of mine got me some lectured
gigs here in Berlin and so I came to
Berlin in January of 64 for the first
time and gave some lectures and that's
when I was asked then to come to Berlin
again to teach for a second year this
time in a an irregular gymnasium which I
did then starting in June of 64 and what
got to you about Berlin that made you
this this the city for you well for the
while it wasn't it was strange but it
was one of the things that I really
loved about Berlin and still do is the
musical life I'm a very great fan of
classical music and I loved the offer
that was here to go to anything and it
was very cheap and you could go to the
Opera you can go to the film money that
that and then I was enjoyed that a lot
and of course I was on my own for the
really first time after college and I
was enjoying life thoroughly and I had
an art gallery which let me meet a lot
of people young people yeah I mean we've
got a picture you sent us here you are
as a young man at the Art Gallery and
how did you set up an art gallery in
what was then of course the divided
Berlin
there was a it was a lark it was the
Germans would call it a Snapseed a it
was just sort of why not I mean I was I
had a lot of time on my hands I was
teaching only 12 hours a week at the
school so what am I going to do with my
time and I thought about a bookshop and
I thought about concerts but an art
gallery seemed the safest and easiest
thing to do a friend of mine a British
fellow who was also a teacher Robert
Davis who was no longer alive I'm sorry
to say helped me and we set up the
gallery and the vetting district which
is through working district brother
working district yes and we and we just
had a great time we should explain that
cause this is the time when the the city
was divided by the Berlin wall
surrounding it and going through the
middle of it yes I mean it have just
been up three years then so did you go
across to the east I mean presumably you
went to the Opera well I went to the
Opera I went to the breast ensemble the
building ensemble I went to the theater
I did that every once in a while it
wasn't easy but it wasn't
impossible it made it was border checks
and exchanging money and surely border
guards but I would I feel safe I wasn't
doing anything illegal
I was within the law and I had an
American passport which was very helpful
it protected me a lot more than it might
do today and I was fine and I got to see
Brill in a lot of brothers I mean I had
a little car a little easy with a door
which opens up in the front is called a
asphalt bubble because it's hardly
distinguishable from anything else it's
but I got me around town and I loved it
and I had a good time moving I learned
this I think this is moving on to the
next decade but now this is you gave it
this is a picture of your wedding I
believe and this was in Poland that's in
Breslau or the Poland Scotland
Bratislava and there I am and all that
sitting to the left of me as my former
wife we divorced happily and after eight
years seven years and we asked we that
was in January of 78 it was very very
tricky very difficult and a certain way
very adventurous Polish antecedents my
father and my mother both were born in
what is now Poland or actually my father
was born in what is now white Russia
Belarus but they came as young children
to the United States and I had no really
polish connections oh okay
nothing I mean I was not I wasn't in
love with Poland I didn't hate Poland it
was for me a foreign country and I
hadn't been there until I had met
despierto okay let's find out some more
about our guest our reporter Maximilian
Phan bimah
visited him at home the other day
I'm at the computer basically by 7:30 8
o'clock in the morning and if nothing
stops me I can be working here until 8
o'clock at night and I don't know why
people do these things because it's so
much work on the other hand it's so
rewarding
Here I am with cristo and jean-claude
and mr. Stricker
Rula has changed so much from the time
this book was done which is now 25 years
ago before the fall of the wall
I thought about reasons for wanting to
wrap the rice stock and mostly I wanted
to have an engagement between art and
politics the Germans call that a snap C
day I mean it comes supposedly when
you're drunk and you think of the
craziest things
this is a picture of never see I will
make sure to get myself a good copy of
it
this is the only monument I know in
which the descendants of the
perpetrators of a terrible event took
the trouble to create something to show
that they're sorry that this happened
and he's here in the studio with me
Michael Cullen who is the man I hadn't
mentioned before responsible for getting
Christo and jean-claude to wrap the rice
stack nearly 20 years ago now before we
talk about that I would like to talk
about where you were at the end there at
the Holocaust Memorial yes
which finally opened in 2005 after years
of intense debate of which you were a
part of and I believe were you against
that particular version of the memorial
not really I was against the site
originally I was against the fact that
it was only for the murdered Jews of
Europe and not for the other where I who
my who I call innocent victims the
people who were born a victim the the
moment they take their first breath the
the homosexuals since he in the round
City and the Roma do now yeah they do
now have a memorial but at the time
there wasn't one prepared or in the
pipeline for them and I wanted one which
included all the innocent victims not
the ones who changed their minds
politically there was a that's an and or
an adult event but when you are born and
you become a victim the very moment
you're born that's the kind of victim I
want you to have a monument for are you
happy with it now I'm not happy with it
but I don't I don't
I'm happy with what a part of it which
is you didn't show or has people haven't
seen that's downstairs there's a huge
exhibition about its extraordinary acts
it's extraordinarily well done and
that's something which I recommend
heavily to anybody visiting Berlin not
just to see upstairs but to go
downstairs and go to the exhibition you
will learn a lot yeah I I must say I was
very moved in and actually I didn't like
the stones that we saw there but after
being to the exhibition and coming up
and walking through them I was actually
so very mu we're on the same page
yeah the ristar yes the story goes in
1971 you sent a postcard to cristo and
jean-claude the artists that who were
famous for wrapping things if we like
saying why don't you wrap the rice tout
it then took 24 years yeah yeah it's so
far the story is true and and I believe
also proper I mean he Christo wanted to
do this but I believe and we have a
picture from you should just show the
rice tower building again yes and with
him in front of it no where you got him
here which I believe was quite difficult
because I heard that he didn't want to
fly here because he didn't want to fly
over East Germany that's right Krista
was a refugee from Bulgaria who had
jumped the border from Prague to Vienna
in 1957 and they were treating his
parents and his brothers very badly and
he was afraid and he was the he was not
yet a citizen of the United States in
1972 he was still not a citizen he
didn't become a citizen and so I think
75 and that meant that he was a he had
one of these one of these transient
passports and he thought if the plane
got shot down over East Germany they
would take him and bring him back to
Bulgaria and set him up against the wall
at any rate he was afraid and we only
convinced him in late 75 to come here
and early 76 and that photograph was
taken just in February of 76 the first
time it's actually seen the Reichstag
one on one well I wonder what before all
this happened what what made you sort of
sit there and think that building the
Reichstag which it should be wrapped by
Western John cold and I I wasn't I
wasn't passionate about it it was just a
matter of why not I mean one of these
one of the things that happens in life
is that you could try to do something
and there's nothing opposing you nothing
opposing the idea and you try it
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't I imagine that a lot of the
experiments
and electricity and chemistry have been
done the same way by people just trying
it and seeing if it works trial and
error and this is an attempt to do
something and if it doesn't work doesn't
work I didn't think it would work I
didn't think it wouldn't work I just
didn't know what would happen I just
sent him a postcard and it worked but it
was really it worked in that he came
obviously - yes and and the ball started
rolling I mean another picture of you on
the left yes and that's how Robert
Crissman leave the Buddhist president
the president's tax President the
Speaker of the the Speaker of the House
call Karstens then that was in March of
77 Cristo and I and called Warburg who
was that of the quids father and dusted
off our explaining to the president of
the Bundestag the person who has to
actually or we thought had to give
permission why were interested they were
to show an interest they they didn't
refuse to see us we didn't come along as
poor petitioners we came along with a
good idea and we came along with a lot
of very very good help very important
people in Germany supported us and sent
letters and so we were we gained
entrance to the to the inner sanctum of
the Bundestag and for many years and we
were doing that all the time when the
end carson's turned us down but we
didn't let ourselves get discouraged and
we just moved on and we pressed on and
we we went through several bundle stacks
presidents the Speaker of the House is
is the American or a German or the
British title the president of the
Parliament and we finally made it in 91
yeah I mean I suppose the fall of the
wall in 1989 help we should explain the
rice house right on the what was the
divide right well actually part of the
masonry of the rice flag was in East
Berlin yes
the band a sort of a kid yeah back at
the east side of it the East facade and
but that didn't stop us at all although
it's there were some people who thought
that that if crystal were to wrap the
rice bag some of the material would flow
into East Berlin and cause a an
international ruckus nothing like that
was in any way involved but the rice tag
was there and it was doing nothing it
was then it was empty
it was basically empty it was used as an
office space for Berlin members of the
Bundestag who didn't have a vote in the
Bundestag in bond so that but they had
their offices in that building to give
it some kind of semblance of a function
for those who are a bit young announce
mission explain bomb was then the
capital of Germany it's right it's quite
complicated really but not really it's
not really complicated we work we went
through it but of course it's for many
people it's now history and some people
didn't live that when did you know it's
gonna happen what I mean it's a really
it's a very at the answer is probably
very unexpected we knew in September 90
get permission
September 93 Christo and I and our team
were invitado which is down the road
about 400 kilometres giving Krista was
lecturing there and I was outside
listening to a portable radio of the
ceremony to decide which city would get
the Olympic Games for 2000 and that was
from Monte Carlo and as mr. Samaranch
pulled the name of Sydney out of the
envelope and Christo and I smiled and he
said the rice tag will be wrapped
because we knew Berlin had nothing else
in its at no plan B to make the city
more attractive then they asked us so we
knew right away and flew excited the
mayor of Berlin came on board and said
yeah I'm for the wrapping of the rice
so we knew at that moment that we would
probably get our dream see our dream
come true at that very very strange but
you didn't ask me that question at any
other time yes that's the real answer
all right great now for those who
perhaps don't know about this
extraordinary event and I met a young
girl in the makeup before doesn't know
about it which is fair enough you know
and for those who remember it too let's
have a look back at some archive footage
from 1995 at the Reichstag in the center
of this city Berlin right where the
border had been between the East and the
West literally this building being
wrapped up like a candy 5 o'clock on a
Monday morning at the hike stock early
risers and photographers were on hand to
witness the big moment
when the first section of cloth would
begin to be lowered a symbol of German
history was being wrapped
around half past seven the front of the
building had vanished behind the silvery
cloth
weather conditions were now perfect a
day earlier the wrapping had been put on
hold due to high winds but still
visitors kept coming in droves
this was also gives us something
extraordinary it'll only happen once in
my lifetime so I'm having a look the
artists who conceived the wrapping of
the high stock Cristo and John Claude
employed over 2,000 helpers for their
project
90 mountain climbers and 120
installation workers to unroll the cloth
members of the German Alpine Club were
proud to be on board
the most exciting thing is the
surroundings here considering the
history of the building and christos
endeavor to wrap the reichstag I get
goosebumps and it makes you really want
to be part of it
delicious AHA Romagna Tobias I
understand an astounding 100,000 square
meters of aluminum-coated polymer fabric
was used in this unique art project
twice the surface area of the whole
building the artists chose the silvery
color for good reason of the building
even more than 15 kilometers of blue
polypropylene rope were needed to hold
the material in place the 32 millimeters
thick cord secured a formidable 60 tons
of fabric we do not wrap the ricetec
simply we created new form
we spent 200 tons of steel to shaping
new form and to create new architecture
in the Reichstag by taking all these
Victorian elements and ornaments hiding
these elements and building completely
new proportion and shaping the writing
and new vision
that new vision led many Germans to
reappraise the building and its history
over the two weeks that remained in
place some 5 million people came to see
the transformed I stock a stunning work
of art making a summer to remember and I
have my very own piece which I didn't
cut out of the artwork you could get
these at the rice tag at the time which
is a piece of the material that's shiny
on this side as we saw there in that
last picture in the evening it looked
really quite beautiful
it reflects all the malignant light of
the what what the sky is giving it's a
like a mirror and it fits a wonderfully
red sunset then it's a sort of reddish
color of the right star I have to say I
was complete skeptic when it was
happening yeah there were so many people
I saw what they doing you know and I
then saw one of these fast forward
things ribbing as I was nursing my small
son in the middle of the night then very
next day I took him there and I was I
was completely entranced and fell in
love with this as did so many people
didn't they seeing is believing
yeah and I wondered though you you were
very busy at the time did you actually
get time to enjoy it oh yes I mean I was
there
sometimes like 15 or 18 hours a day I
was showing people the building and
going around with them and enjoying
things I was also cutting newspaper
clippings for the the our press
portfolio as it were to document every I
mean I'm a historian and I document
things as as things go along and we were
doing all these things at the same time
and I enjoyed it thoroughly I mean of
course it's God it's 19 years ago now I
still get handshakes people noticed me
on the street yeah I know and not only
even not only in Berlin for having come
up with the idea and and I was there all
the time I'm still Krista we're still
friends we we talk
we each other every once in a while this
Saturday Jean Claude died sadly in four
and a half years ago it's a was tragedy
but Krishna was soldiering on as it were
working on other projects to answer a
question which I wasn't asked is about
how these things get financed oh yeah I
need my mind yeah I was sort of thinking
about that and of course it was Dalton
by Christos selling his preparatory
drawings Christo and jean-claude so all
the drawings up front after the project
is done there are no more drawings made
so as so but these works sell for many
many thousands of dollars even tens of
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
dollars and they bring in the money
which pays for the laborers and the
material and the scaffolding and
everything else that's involved
including his travels that's all paid
for that way not posters not the little
gimmicks and and the material which you
just showed is a present of anybody who
just asked her a piece of material
yeah they got I know I did all you had
to do was ask her Cristo was did that
originally to stop people from actually
cutting it yeah it's a very preventive
message and everybody is enthralled and
you even have a piece of it so well III
am I was actually making a TV program
and they I got a little surprised here
extraordinary it was an extraordinary
time which I remember very well because
my first ever television show as a
presenter was about the rap price tag
and you and remember this because you
made hundreds of interviews at the time
but one of them was with a rather
nervous
Deutsche Welle presenter and it has to
be said a big suit you live in Berlin
how do you think it's done for the image
of the Germany and the Germans I know
that there have been interesting aspects
of it in the American press and at the
French press the French have been very
good about it the British have been
less than Pleasant about it they've been
somewhat they've been sarcastic and the
Americans have had pluses and minuses
and I don't know how the other national
agents have reacted because I haven't
seen the TV and of course I'm waiting
for the newspaper articles to come in
very quickly would you do it all again
Oh certainly
Michael : thank you very much there we
were surprised yeah we have know what to
say before the program very good as I
say this that was actually by very first
television program you were to know this
you were going from what interview to
the next of the next it shouldn't be our
last yeah okay you were mentioning the
Brits were sarcastic the French loved it
I said before yes I was quite cynic
it all turned around though didn't it I
mean people came to love it didn't they
well it was extraordinary happy well the
thing is that is it its meaning for
everybody the part Christo was very wise
who and he resisted he resisted all
kinds of attempts to infuse this project
with some kind of extra meaning it's
there's an old client called WYSIWYG
what you see is what you get in the art
world it's what you see and it's all
there and you can project anything you
want and it's no no different than a
work of Mozart piano concerto or a
string quartet you listen to it you
enjoy it if you don't perhaps you don't
enjoy it that's also possible it goes
away and it's part of your memory it's
part of your feelings but you don't have
to embrace it you don't have to love it
you don't have to profess you don't have
to go to confession it's all there for
them happening and you can take it or
you can leave it yeah and I mean
actually you did this for love you
didn't profit from this there was no
unfortunately not profit no a small
profit is on your lapel if we can get a
camera
because my guest is one of the few
foreigners actually to received the
Bundys for dienst Christ the federal
order of merit which is they I know you
you have something else but it's very
small on your lapel well this is what
this is the the the highest award it's
one of the highest awards and many
Germans get them very few foreigners
that's true and I got it from Johannes
Val who was then president in 2003 I
think I was the only non German getting
it that day and but it was and there's a
huge cross which one who gets with it
with it with it with a ribbon and but
that's only for the day that you get it
and maybe if the president says we are
having a major ball and you're invited
and you must wear all your medals then
that's when you do it but most main all
the soldiers that you see working around
these things
batteries of medals there are big things
behind those things but this is what you
just wear on your suit and this is it
really changed attitude to Germany
didn't it I think so I think that the
wrapping of the rice dog created a happy
mood it made people feel less
apprehensive about Germany Germany's
Germans having fun yes
Germans having almost like the last
night of the Proms when you see the the
Londoners having all their dances and
jigs at the the last night of the Proms
this was Germany having a good time it
was really in a certain sense the
festival for reunification five years
after the date I mean there wasn't
anything like this before with just
being open and having a good time and
that they came day and night they came
at all times of the day there were no
plane seats
to be gotten there were no train seats
to be gotten after a few days the word
had spread around 96% of all German
adults knew something about the right
stack that's more than who knew about
the neighbor who is the current
president at the time yeah it's it's a
terrible thing to say but the media had
a major effect on that and and we had a
wonderful experience and as you say from
outside it I think that and the World
Cup of 2006 changed attitudes about this
country yes one of them I'll move on to
it actually the the it we have this
questionnaire and you answered a couple
of things and you said the best kept
secret in Germany who said that she is
the one I don't know but you also said
is the fact that there is a lot of humor
there's a cliche the Germans don't have
a sense of humor there see really it's
rubbish isn't it they do have a sense of
fear that's wonderful poetry and
literature and music all kinds of things
with a lot of funerals which I enjoy mmm
yeah and one of the great examples of
this is the German comedian who's your
favorite I believe it Laurie OH who I
know is my guest favorites humorist is
more about one of the Great's of German
comedy
and I'll just have you actually knew the
man yes he lived in my street for many
years towards the end of his life and we
exchanged pleasantries on the street
every once in a while and a couple of
his very closest friends are friends of
mine and I will make sure that one of
them sees this well he as it said in the
piece he sort of played on cliches and
things about I mean I wanted to ask you
about a couple we've we've dispelled the
cliche about humor okay okay yes all the
Germans abrupt people say they're abrupt
um you know sort of serious I mean I
always think it's it's two things the
language is a bit hard sounding and that
I find the gems very honest but I don't
know what you think well I don't I
wouldn't make remarks about them being
honest or dishonest I think they're like
everybody else or some who are and some
who are that's sure and that's number
one the second thing is about whether
they're erupted sometimes they are
sometimes they're relatively abrasive on
the other hand I have many many friends
who are the opposite of brace being
abrasive they're quite cozy and pleasant
and funny and we get along we laugh a
lot yeah I have but I know that I have
many people I know many people who don't
laugh at all I'm sorry for them yeah I
know you like their what the Germans
call their disgust yawns cool try
they're sort of they do like to discuss
things that is I think a fair one I
think that's a fair one and I think it's
a reasonable one yeah I like I think
that's very important
in a city like Berlin which is full of
competing ideas and antagonistic ideas
about how the city should go forward
that they discuss these things and out
front before they make terrible mistakes
I mean they still do
terrible mistakes they have did they did
they make a mistake about the Berlin
Wall because I know you were on a
commission after the wall came down of
where it should remain and I hear from
people who visit where is it I can't
find it I want to see where it was our
Commission suggested that many more
segments of the wall remain standing and
the powers that be rejected some of
those sites for political or urban istic
reasons
at any rate only four or five things are
really up there I would have said ten
would have been much much better and but
they didn't accept all my our it's not
only me but we have a few people on the
board and on the Commission and we made
suggestions they weren't always followed
and one of the if you like one of the
famous bits to outsiders
is the East Side Gallery which has got
paintings on it but you're not a fan of
that I'm not a great fan of it but
because that's it's really working on a
on an emotional basis about the wall and
what it meant and not about the art
which is on it I don't think the art is
very very good it'll be there for many
many years as us as an expression of the
times
Berlin went through but it's not for me
if it were by itself if most of those
works stood by themselves they wouldn't
stand by themselves okay we talked about
the disco songs culture you'd like
discussion so I want to ask you anything
the end but you've been here 50 years I
know you've retained your American
passport you choose to have an American
passport but do you think you're perhaps
more German than American now no I don't
I think I'm probably less for like this
a very famous American lawyer came to
Germany in the 30s to follow some trials
here and he was asked how good his
French and German was and
said well in France my German is good
and in Germany my French is good I think
that the Americans look at me and say
well he's taking a lot of German
Germany's on and the Germans look at me
and said well he's still pretty American
so I think it's a matter of who's
looking at me and who's talking with me
who decides whether I'm more one or the
other I think that I have retained a lot
of American characteristics and probably
have taken on a few German characters
Angela you're staying here you're not
going I am here for the duration yeah
now they say history repeats itself and
you're a historian so I did what we've
had this year we've had the European
elections and there's lots of talk about
Europe what came out of the European
elections many things but one of the
main things was the sharp rise of
anti-immigration parties I mean do you
see looking into your crystal ball ask
you finally you know do you see that
getting a real problem here in Europe I
think it'll be around for a long time
there is nationalism still here and it's
not over
it hasn't been overcome by all the
various mechanisms including a common
currency and even certain countries like
Great Britain are not going along with
the common currency it'll be here for a
while I think it'll always be something
which comes up and goes down depending
upon the economies and various
politicians it's something to be you
have to keep fighting it it's like it's
like a common cold
it'll come back and it'll not go away
completely but you can live with it and
it's really more important that the
people who want to come here today
there's a very good article about the
fact that Germany is so the European
Europe is so attractive to thousands of
millions of people outside of Europe
that they want to come here and the fact
that it is attractive is its problem
well I'll have to cut you off there
Michael Cullen it's been fascinating to
talk to you thank you for watching this
man is a
as a history book in himself and as
written the definitive book on the rice
town look it up Michael Ness : thank you
very much for being with us today on
inside Germany bye-bye